ah la la j'aimerais tellement parlé de
game of thrones mais je ne peux pas en
parler tout seul
bienvenue dans cette vidéo un petit peu
particulière où nous allons vous
partagez diddy maistre thibault isf et
moineaux déception quant à la série de
game of thrones mais avant cela petit
disclaimer suite à la vidéo 5 avengers
son côté qui vous avez plutôt plus et
puis qui moi surtout m'avait vraiment
amusé à faire j'ai décidé de renouveler
l'expérience néanmoins c'est compliqué
de définir quelque chose de son côté
dans une série sorti dans son entièreté
et c'est même compliqué en soi de dire
ça c'est ce côté car sous côté hockey
mais dans quel sens
est ce que john et son côté car ils
auraient pu accomplir plus de choses
est ce que le roi de la nuit et ce côté
car il est mort trop vite et aurait pu
faire plus de dégâts dans la série la
question étant compliqué ça a très vite
au final tourner autour de notre
déception car après tout si on est déçu
d'un élément c'est qu'on aurait souhaité
en voir plus technique
donc voilà c'est ça le message on n'est
pas là pour descendre goat nous sommes
tous les quatre des normes fans de la
série et si on vous partage aujourd'hui
nos déceptions c'est car justement on
aurait aimé en voir plus bref je laisse
la parole et je reviendrai vers vous
plus tard que la vidéo commence
ah la la la prophétie liée à à sarajevo
le prince qui fut promis si vous
préférez est probablement l'un des
points que j'ai trouvé les plus
intéressants durant ma découverte de la
série game of thrones l'univers était
déjà de base plutôt très mystérieux et
ce dès la première saison est
l'introduction de l'aspect prophétique
n'a fait qu'améliorer les choses par
ailleurs le personnage de mélissandre à
travers lequel on apprend davantage sur
le fam azor haye a été très longtemps
le personnage préféré de nombreux fans
c'est bien sûr dans la saison 2 de goth
que mélissandre nous initie à la
profession autour du prince qui fut
promis l'occasion pour elle mais aussi
pour le spectateur de commencer un jeu
qui se déroulera sur de nombreuses
années
celui de choisir le champion du seigneur
de la lumière qui selon elle est est à
nice et qui selon les fans étaient john
daenerys ou même dans de rares cas
johra et oui même lui plus tard on a
également l'occasion de découvrir les
pouvoirs de ce fameux seigneur de la
lumière à travers d'autres personnages
des pouvoirs qui change clairement la
donne permettant même de ressusciter les
morts bref c'était alors logique pour le
spectateur qu'il allait réellement y
avoir un élu est une explication
sauf que comme vous le savez les choses
se sont passées de manière très
différente et encore aujourd'hui tout ce
qui est lié à mélissandre senneurs de la
lumière à la zohra ayew que sais-je
reste dans l'ombre même qu'aucune
explication n'est fournie pour le grand
désarroi des fans de goth adeptes de cet
aspect l'univers de la série de soi
d'une certaine manière tout ce qui est
mystique en un même été très nombreux à
voir en berric d'arion l'une des pièces
maîtresses capable d'apprendre a entre
autres john à se servir d'une épée
enflammé histoire de faire écho aux
légendes ainsi qu aux prophéties autour
du fameux à zohra haye le héros
légendaire munich d'illumination l'épée
de légende
finalement rien du tout et c'est le côté
paix en acier valérien sera utilisé par
la série faisons d'une simple d'agaune
acier valérien le ti capable de
terrasser les ténèbres
le roi de la nuit alors oui bien sûr que
l'adac à celle aussi des mystères mais
bref tout ça pour dire que beaucoup de
choses ils ont été présentés mais très
rare sens l avoir servi le récit aux
mêmes ont été éclairés à se demander à
quoi ça a servi d'amorcé tout ça si au
final ça n'a servi à rien le prince qui
fut promis est en finale ment pas
si promis que ça à noter que même s'il a
existé dans la série sans être pointés
du doigt il n'a clairement pas été aussi
important que le laisse penser le show
bref je vous laisse alors imaginez la
frustration de tous les fans qui n'ont
pas pu avoir des réponses avec toute
cette intrigue et croyez moi qu'elle
était plutôt bien fourni mais finalement
sans réelle importance
voilà dommage même si c'était cool quand
même mais dommage a la base je
souhaitais vous parlez du maître de la
lumière pour moi c'est un élément qui
fut très sous côté et très peu exploité
dans la série mais l'ami et recettes
vous l'a déjà mentionné par le biais de
la prophétie d'azo rails ou à oreille
donc si je devais nommer une autre
déception c'est bien le choix de faire
de branne le roi des six couronnes oui
si ce but que le nord est est redevenu
indépendant
en fait ce n'est pas tant que ça le
choix de faire de branne leroy qui me
dérange mais plutôt le message derrière
comme vous le savez brun était un
personnage un petit peu particulier dans
la série ce dernier a perdu l'usagé de
ses jambes à cause de jamie lannister
suite à de nombreuses péripéties bran à
braver le nord et au delà du mur afin de
mieux comprendre l'histoire du monde et
la menace qu'elle roi de la nuit
il deviendra donc la nouvelle corneille
à trois yeux pouvant voir partout que ce
soit le passé le présent et même le
futur mais c'est là que ça devient
dérangeant en fait
bran sur le trône pourquoi pas je
comprends l'idée en soi comme le dit
thirion branagh est un symbole l'unique
personne ayant connaissance de
l'histoire du monde
des vérités cachées et celui qui
pourrait même prévenir l'avenir
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi le roi de la
nuit le visaient
bran est véritablement unique puis quand
bien même scénaristiquement c'est un
stark et dès la fin de la première
saison n'ait devait être le nouveau roi
avant de se faire trahir
donc techniquement la boucle est bouclée
mais bran affirment qu'ils ne
souhaitaient pas être roi
alors qu'ils nous montrent tout l'averse
pourquoi crois tu que j'ai fait tout ce
chemin sérieusement et tu dis que tu ne
voulait pas être roi tout le long de la
série depuis qu'il est devenu la
corneille à trois yeux bran à laisser
l'histoire se faire et la même orientés
par moment jusqu'à ce point précis où il
devient le roi une histoire qui a
traduit un nombre incalculable de mort
c'est tout con mais par exemple bran
savez pour daenerys il savait ce qu'elle
allait faire dans l'épisode 5
et même si politiquement je peux
comprendre que ce soit compliqué pour
brin d'intervenir en mode agent à me
fais gaffe elle va tout cramé il faut
que tu l'as tu bats il l'a même pas fait
il a même pas prévenu il a rien fait du
tout en fait
alors qu'il savait alors que pour le roi
de la nuit il savait que arias allait
intervenir sinon il n'aurait jamais fait
la pas inutilement est ce que vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
en fait brown affirme que chaque acte de
chaque personnage les amener jusqu'à ce
point précis comme jamie par exemple il
ne lui en veux pas car c'est justement
cet acte du fait de l'avoir poussée et
du haut de la tour qui fait que jamie a
pu changer et se battre aux côtés du
nord maintenant donc ce qui veut dire
que chaque acte a son importance et bran
du coup ayant connaissance de ça et des
potentiels futurs tels dr strange a
placé ses pions ce n'est pas du tout un
hasard si ce dernier a raconté toute son
histoire attirions sans s'attirer on
n'aurait jamais proposé son nom lors de
l'ultime épisode il serait resté
brandon star que random l'idée de mettre
bran sur le trône n'est pas idiot du
tout en soi mais le message derrière
n'est pas sain et c'est un petit peu une
déception pour moi car la fin a beau
être douce elle est quand même vachement
amer
game of thrones est une oeuvre qui s'est
construite sur quasiment dix années et
plus on avance et plus on pouvait voir
que la série dévier des livres écrits
par grr martin
avec le recul et la lecture il est vrai
que certains éléments sont largement
sous exploité dans l'adaptation des bio
d'autant qu'elle pourrait apporter un
plus indéniable à des intrigues déjà
bien fouillé à la lumière de tout cela
il est très difficile de se pencher
vraiment sur un seul cas précis mais
s'il ya bien un élément ou plutôt un
rêve qu'on m'a vendu et qui termine en
véritable pétard mouillé
la première image qui me vient en tête
et la compagnie doré pour retrouver une
trace de la première mention de la
compagnie doré dans la série il faut
remonter à un échange entre davos et
stannis baratheon dans la saison 4 la
main du roi conseils sont souverains de
recouvrir à l'intervention de la
compagnie doré mais le roc stannis
baratheon refuse cette éventualité en
disant qu'il ne gagnera pas son trône
grâce à l'aide de ses mercenaires
davos avait pourtant évoqué la puissance
de cette force de frappe
parlant d'une armée de dix mille hommes
qui ne brise jamais un contrat tout
lecteur sait à quel point la compagnie
doré est toute puissante faisant peur
aux d'autres acquis sur le continent des
sauces et étant engagé par les sites est
libre pour les aider dans leurs
querelles territoriales créées à la base
par igor river un bâtard targaryen
soutenant le clan des feux noir ou black
fire en anglais la compagnie doré est
une arme est colossal qui joue sur sa
réputation acquise au fil des ans
maniant une des épées ancestral de la
famille targaryen et plongeant le crâne
de ses capitaines dans de l'or en fusion
elle fera plusieurs interventions dans
le passé pour tenter de déstabiliser le
trône de fer
ce n'est pas pour rien que le mode hors
et renvoie à son goût pour l'or mais
aussi à la couleur brillante de l'armure
de ses soldats
lorsque cersei s'empresse d'annoncer à
jimmy fin de saison 7 qu'elle a utilisés
lors des tailles réelles de au jardin
pour rembourser la banque de braves
hausse mais aussi pour engager la
compagnie doré j'étais le premier à être
impatient de voir cette armée à l'écran
cersei le dit elle-même
ils ont au moins vingt mille hommes et
des éléphants le tout sous le
commandement du capitaine arye
strickland
si l'épisode 1 de la saison 8 commencé
très bien en introduisant cette armée
arrivant à por real on pouvait voir que
le design était tout à fait convaincant
une armure dorée caractéristiques un
capitaine assez ressemblants houari
strickland délivre son épée avec des
crânes un petit peu partout le tout pour
un nouvel ennemi redoutable à vaincre
quelle ne fut pas ma frustration
lorsqu'ils ont évoqué que les éléphants
n'était pas de la partie
parce qu'il n'aime pas voyager en mer
c'est assez ironique car si l'on se
penche sur le cas des livres
la compagnie doré a réussi à emmener
avec elle des éléphants sur le continent
de westeros lors de son invasion
est-ce que cela cachait une volonté des
scénaristes de se débarrasser des effets
spéciaux encombrant pour le combat final
on se souvient très bien avoir vu des
mammouths lors de la bataille du mur
opposant la garde de nuit au sauvageon
en fin de saison 4 et pour une bataille
finale en saison 8
je dois dire que cet élément absent est
pour le moins surprenant en levant une
force de frappe colossale à la compagnie
doré des éléphants face à une armée
ennemie
ça aurait été vraiment très surprenant
et là on aurait pu avoir quelque chose
de vraiment titanesque
pourtant la véritable frustration ce
n'est pas forcément les éléphants elle
réside plus dans la tournure des
événements pour eux dans l'épisode 5 de
la saison 8
massés devant l'entrée de port réal les
soldats et harry strickland se présente
et semble décidé à offrir un combat
épique au nord bien leur faisant face et
là qu'est ce que c'est que ça quelle ne
fut pas ma déception en voyant daenerys
a déboulé avec son lance-flammes
ambulants et toi ni il est en l'espace
de quelques secondes à l'image d'harry
strickland redoutable militaire et fin
tacticien dans les livres qui ne dégaine
même pas son épée et qui tourne le dos
en s'enfuyant comme un lâche avant de
périr dans l'ignorance la plus totale
game of thrones nous offre une vision
totalement biaisée de la réalité sous
qu'autant le pouvoir est l'intérêt d'une
telle force de frappe son impact dans la
série est proche de zéro le monde
n'ayant pas évolué
avec ou sans leur intervention la
compagnie doré ne laissera l'image que
d'un véritable gâchis une compagnie
cramer et doré au feu du dragon
longtemps teasé comme l'armé ultime mais
qui ne jouera que le rôle d'allumettes
vivante dans la dernière saison
difficile désormais de prendre au
sérieux cette dernière même si pour le
coup je vous encourage plutôt à lire les
livres qui assurément vous offriront une
autre vision du potentiel de la
compagnie doré
[Musique]
j'aime pas taper sur game of thrones est
bon c'est bien un truc qui m'a déçu
c'est le roi de la nuit
typiquement le genre de personnage
sous-exploité dont on aurait aimé en
apprendre beaucoup plus en fait il ya
trois grands problèmes à propos du roi
de la nuit le premier c'est qu'il est
difficile voire même impossible de dire
que dans game of thrones
il y à des méchants peut-être plus
parler d'antagonisme on veut va dire il
y à des méchants que ce soit sur site à
iwuy nous-mêmes ramsay on nous invite
souvent dans la série a essayé de nous
mettre à leur place
on comprend leur point de vue leur
parcours surtout leurs enjeux et je
pense donc que si beaucoup n'ont pas
vraiment apprécié cette dernière saison
gameiro seconde c'est qu'on attendait
tous un traitement plus ou moins
similaire avec le roi de la nuit
inconsciemment c'est parce qu'on se
disait ça peut pas être simplement le
gros méchant et ça va aller au delà de
ça il ya plus que ça j'étais vraiment
persuadé que la série allait nous
inviter justement nous mettre à sa place
ça va comprendre son parcours ses enjeux
sa vision des choses ça va être
méchamment dit et je veux pas taper sur
game of thrones a mais la série s'est
rabaissé à vouloir en faire juste un
gros méchant on pourra même se dire que
c'est indigne de la série de lui avoir
fait subir ce traitement aussi pauvre
avec aussi peu d'approfondissement et
qu'après sept ans d'attentes n'aura pu
peut-être demander un peu mieux le
deuxième point qui est tout aussi
important si ce n'est plus c'est que la
première scène la toute première scène
de la série c'est les marcheurs blanc on
commence avec nos premiers pas dans cet
univers et on nous dit ayez peur des
marcheurs blanc c'est ça la menace et
tout au long de la série et plusieurs
personnages qui vont dire que le jeu des
trônes c'est de la merde à côté de cette
menace que la réelle guerre c'est celle
du nord c'est celle des vivants contre
les maures et qu'en gros on s'en fout de
qui siège sur le trône car le plus
important du coup c'est les marchands
blanc est donc celui qui est à leur tête
le roi de la nuit et finalement le roi
de la nuit on le verra va donc très peu
de temps et la longue nuit qu'on nous
avait promis pendant des années s'est
terminé à 2 heures du matin donc ça ça a
été un peu on peut pas dire que c'était
indigne du personnage parce que le
personnage en fin de compte on le
connaît pas on le voit que très peu mais
ouais c'est un peu indigne de la série
surtout d'une fin de
deux séries tout simplement de ne pas
l'avoir approfondie c'est comme si on
nous avait teasé un gros climax au sujet
du roi de la nuit qui finalement n'est
jamais arrivé un peu un gros build up
pour rien on en attendait tellement plus
à son sujet et c'est le troisième point
c'est tout simplement nos attentes en
tant que fan internet a été nourrie de
tellement de théorie à propos du roi de
la nuit même niveau moeurs de la série
niveau goodies tellement de trucs avec
le roi de la nuit je suis sûr que tout
fan de game of thrones à sa petite
figurine ou quoi du roi de la nuit moi
j'en fais partie
car au fond et on pensait tout ce qu'on
allait en apprendre plus sur ce gars
quoi
qui est-il vraiment que ressent-il
pourquoi fait-il ça etc
on a mis tellement d'attentes tellement
d'espoir dans ce roi de la nuit et quand
ceux des deux précédents points car on
nous a jamais habitué à un gros méchant
comme ça gratuitement dans la série et
parce qu'on nous a rappelé justement
tout au long des épisodes que la réelle
menace c'était nuit et au final non même
au niveau des victimes je veux dire elle
n'a pas fait tant de victimes que ça
quand on y pense la longue nuit qui pour
beaucoup auraient dû est la grosse
bataille de fin de la série a fait très
peu de victimes c'est bizarre je
rappelle quand même que khal drogo est
mort à cause d'une infection que robert
est mort à cause d'un sanglier et quand
il ya le roi de la nuit qui se pointe
quasi personne qui meurt c'est bizarre
c'est bizarre donc personnages sous coté
sous exploité sous tout ce que vous
voulez voilà on s'y faire on s'y fait
mais quand je repense à mon mois de il
ya un an
s'ils savaient les déceptions qui laisse
prendre à propos du roi de la mivoie la
voile à choisy le roi de la nuit vous
pour ça parce que ça reste ma déception
de la série même si j'aime pas taper
dessus parce que on oublie tous quand
même fait des beaucerons ça a été
extraordinaire qu'il ya un avant et un
après game of thrones qu'on a vécu de
très bons souvenirs dans cette série
donc voilà c'est juste ce petit truc
le roi de la nuit ce petit truc ça
résume absolument tout ce qu'on vient de
dire le roi de la nuit n'aurait jamais
dû être simplement un petit truc
merci vraiment du fond du coeur d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je suis vraiment
ultra heureux de vous l'avoir produite
et je tenais vraiment à remercier mes
trois compagnons d'avoir assisté à cette
dernière
j'aurais proposé l'idée comme ça ils ont
dit oui sans hésiter ils sont investis
et franchement c'est vraiment top
un grand grand merci à eux je vous
redirige bien évidemment vers la chaîne
du broc et recef l'un des plus grands
explorateurs d'univers que youtube est
connue je vous redirige également vers
la chaîne du vieux maistre thibault un
très grand vidéaste un très bon ami très
dirigé dans la dark fantasy entre game
of thrones the witcher seigneur des
anneaux tout ce type d'univers à sa
thibault c'est le chef est évidemment un
énorme merci à 10 dit clairement si je
devais faire une vidéo dit chen de
théorie je mettrai diddy dedans c'est
clair non franchement un énorme merci à
veut aller voir leurs chaînes évidemment
et puis bah c'était argot rock n'hésitez
pas à laisser un petit pouce bleu un
petit commentaire à vous abonner que le
lionheart soit avec vous ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]